we're currently in the second half of
this topic that was sort of introduced
with quadratics that we talked about
parabola and then we introduced this
weird funky idea that was related to a
parabola
sounded like an insect remember so I
always call this locusts I equally hear
it pronounced Lucas but I think that
sounds too much like I'm like the crazy
grasshoppers so I I say locusts so you
don't confuse it this is just another
way of thinking about the geometry of a
parabola and we had a look at we saw
there are other shapes you could also
express with it okay now we're going to
continue digging even deeper further
into parabola and quadratics and this is
the mechanism this is a tool we're going
to use to do it
parametric's is the name of the topic it
deals with if you want to write this
down that deals with parameters what's a
parameter it will be easier for me to
explain what a parameter is with a and
example before I give you a definition
so here's my example and this is what
you're going to put on this graph down
here suppose suppose you want to graph
two quantities against each other
in different countries you wanted to
graph obesity rates against numbers of
TVs in households okay
what would this graph look like what
would this graph look like as the number
of TVs in a household on average
increases in a country right you've got
some countries that have no TVs at all
and then you've got some countries where
it's like we have six TVs per household
because everyone needs to have two
screens to look at at the same time what
do you think would happen to the obesity
rates and I think we could all predict
it might look I mean I'm grossly
oversimplifying but whatever it might
look something like this right
I you're there are countries with no TVs
and they have very low obesity rates
apparently zero and then there are
countries that as you get more and more
TVs in the house you get more and more
incidences of obesity now I say this is
a gross oversimplification but it is in
fact what happens basically in reality
now the question then becomes
what do you make of this what patent do
you see what conclusion do you draw what
conclusion could you draw from this
I mean I've drawn it as a linear thing
it could it could have been like you
know a curve like this or a curve like
that but they're all going to be crazy
what conclusion would you draw okay so
you look you see I think there's a um
there's a connection between these two
clearly correlation when you see two
things I'm going going up together or
falling together doesn't mean that one
causes the other
in fact that's kind of the main point
here that I would suggest there's a
there's a third variable going on that's
underneath here that you can't see it
it's a lot of my graph because my graph
only has two axes there's a third
variable that leads to both of these and
I guess you know again oversimplifying
you could call it something like a
country's economic prosperity maybe you
got more prosperity people buy more TVs
because they've got more disposable
income and when you have more economic
prosperity people have large amounts of
food they've got on healthier food and
so BC rates go up okay so this idea here
of somewhere hiding in here financial
prosperity it's this other measurement
it's this other measurement it's kind of
hidden there or it's off to one side and
in fact that is exactly what parameter
means parameter like when you have a
metric of some kind a metric is when you
measure something okay so this is a
measurement or a value Pera literally
means off to one side so you know how
there are paramedics right paramedics
are people who work alongside all the
other medical professionals you know you
have a parabola right a parabola is the
shape when you throw something off to
one side right we'll explore that in
projectile motion later next year
anytime you see the word para like
paralegal okay it's just when you've got
something and something else over on the
side a parameter is a measurement or a
value that's off to one side or hidden
right
you can't see it here and so the first
reason why we talk about Peron is why we
introduce them is for the sake of
clarity we want to clarify what is
really going on in this situation is
there some kind of value that is really
driving what's going on that actually
makes this happen and make this happen
because neither of these are directly
related to each other they're all
related to this parameter okay
there's another reason which is
convenience because this idea of a
parameter you actually have already
encountered it we just didn't tell you
that it was a parameter on your next
Cartesian plate here can you draw for me
the unit circle now the unit circle is a
very important shape we've been dealing
with it for a while which is why as soon
as I say unit circle you know what this
shape is it's a circle with the center
at 0 0 the origin and what else do you
know about the unit circle it has a
radius of 1 hence the unit circle right
so you got 1 1 negative 1 and negative 1
this is the unit circle why do I care
about the unit circle does any order to
remember and I don't expect the answer
is yes but it might be yes they don't
remember why we introduced the unit
circle in the first place which topic
did we introduce it in you guys are
great we introduced the intrigue why do
we do it intriguing because there are
right-angled triangles hiding everywhere
in the unit circle right once you
recognize there's writing with triangles
hiding everywhere they all have a
hypotenuse of one because it's the unit
circle and from this we can infer what
what did we say about the coordinates of
any point in circumference when you
think about this right angle triangle it
turns a trick we could say that the x
coordinate of a point on the
circumference is cos theta does anyone
remember this okay we're trying to
redefine sighting cause we're trying to
get outside of write angular triangles
and get angles that were like bigger
than 19 like obtuse angles or or reflex
angles down here okay we said that the
expo
it was cause and the y-coordinate was
same now I want you to look carefully at
those coordinates do you see that I
could say X&Y right - two values but
really there's a third value one off to
the side that's hidden which is really
driving both of them do you see that
so theater is the real thing that's
going on it makes X happen it makes Y
happen and here's who's where theater is
we defined it as the angle between what
is it being between it's the angle
between the positive x axis and the
radius up to wherever your point is okay
so if I put my my point over here and
the radius we go this way I'd measure my
angle all the way around something we're
very familiar with now okay
so again just reinforcing this guy here
theta right it's the parameter and the
reason why having it is convenient is
because now I can describe any point on
the circumference of this circle and
it's they're supplying two values and X
and/or Y I can just supply you with one
with the parameter does that make sense
like I can say a hundred and eighty-nine
degrees and everyone can tell me where
that is I told you one number and you
were able to locate where that was I
guess it would be somewhere around here
okay so you don't need to you only need
one that's clearly more convenient okay